guys welcome back to the Samsung stage
I'm cam Robinson filling in for Chris
again I've been following him around the
game spot live set up he was off in the
game spot stage before I followed up and
now back here and I am very excited to
be sitting down with one of the people
who basically makes Batman that's a
great design your business cards
it is maker of bat back skin because
that because Batman that's great as much
better than my business contacts welcome
to the stage pleasure to have you here
thank you
III it's underway Batman is here again
where were you last year where were you
last year I was in the trenches last
year I don't work in London so ever
since even before we finish Batman
Arkham City we went straight into the
design and development of Batman Arkham
Knight and that's where we've been so to
finally be here I never thought this
would come I never thought this day
would come
where we shouldn't talking about the
Batmobile battle mode all of these
reveals that that we've been working on
and keeping secret for so long we can
finally just shout let it out it's a
great feeling you feel free to literally
show it if you feel like aspire to make
the like baby for you by all means shut
away I do like shouting I might get that
way let's go yesterday how did it like
tell me how have you heard that reveal
where for you to I mean we kind of tease
you tease the Batmobile a bit like a few
weeks maybe even a month beforehand but
you showed up a whole lot of new stuff
yesterday we've actually got the b-roll
from the beautiful gameplay from that so
let's throw that up actually tingling so
let the first thing they're like there
was an audible ooh in the GameSpot war
we went on yesterday because it when we
get when we see Batman walking out here
yeah well we start off in Bruce Wayne's
office at the top of Wayne Towers so
Batman's suiting up into this awesome
new bat suit which is much more kind of
design you know Batman Arkham Knight is
Batman going to war in Gotham so it's
much more kind of handy eyesore but it's
still got everything he needs in terms
of flexibility to be agile and the first
thing is mat it just looks beautiful and
is raw distance his reveal of Gotham
City what engine are we running here is
this is unreal tree unreal sorry yeah
we've been working on unreal tree for
Arkham City and then we developed a
whole load of tools internally at
Rocksteady to hit this kind of fidelity
level so you know there's a lot that
goes into creating the atmosphere of
Gotham City so it doesn't just feel like
any city its Gotham City and that means
rain the reflections that's theater that
the moon every aspect of the atmosphere
that you're expecting Gotham City has to
be right
there's this running on em this way on
ps4 PC where's the PC bills PC bill and
this point here where we calling the
Batmobile and then take off that kind of
transition from man to machine
controlling Batman straight into the
Batmobile
is just something that we've been really
focused on because it's such an
emotional thing you know there's quite a
lot of destructibility there so even
just like a barrier so it's a lot of
Gotham City this time around yeah
trash a ball in your tank of a Batmobile
it's epic destruction you know that was
something that was important to us
because the idea of driving the
Batmobile isn't just about driving fast
it's about taking any shortcut you want
to get to your objective point moving up
skill in the way exactly and then the
transformation into battle mode is
another big feature that we're really
diving deep into here at e3 because the
Batmobile has this functionality that
means that Batman can fight back yeah
against the military forces that the
arkham knight has brought in to go
pursue so here's like a Batman cannon
question right surely but back Batman
doesn't kill right but then he's
basically got a tank and he's firing
missiles of people doesn't that kill
people firing missiles at unmanned
drones drones these tanks are under
control of the Arkham Knight gosh yeah
and that military force is a combination
of live and drone targets so if Batman
comes up against a platoon of infantry
for example he will switch automatically
to less than lethal but you see there
that massive missile barrage that takes
out all of those tanks in one hit so
it's like a supercharged move and then
hit top speed you can eject out and then
you're back up there gliding across the
skyline of Gotham City you know being in
the middle of a battle and then within a
heartbeat
it's just serene and quiet and then you
can focus on where you go next but I
really love that kind of emotional
interplay so the city I mean it's it
looks pretty expensive is it is how
early in the game are we here like
there's a whole city start off open to
us Batman or do you unlock sections or
has it work you develop as you move
through the city so the idea of building
out the entirety of Gotham City was a
huge technical and creative challenge
for us
but something that was so critical
because we know that that's what gamers
want that's what we are on deals a
studio as well so there's very distinct
districts within Gotham City and you can
see this the design of the buildings
here are much more kind of modern much
more commercial you see the game just
start to go there do you feel this
because this is the moment of Terror
last night that we dropped at the Sony
e3 press conference we wanted to make a
big reveal of Scarecrow and this was
being played live and that's exactly
show for us beer at e3 in the context of
a press conference is technical
disruption something going wrong and
ultimately the game crashing so
scarecrow uses fear as a weapon and we
wanted to give everyone a sense of what
as a game developed but genuine fear
feels like so scarecrow crashing the
game and then breaking through that
crash to reveal scarecrow was something
that we've got it as an idea really
excited us and then to see it come off
last night and people like whoa was that
deliberate was that intentional I was
sitting there in the seat just sweating
but I think it went down pretty well
absolutely you know I definitely don't
think there was that like wait what yeah
this made to happen yeah
what's going on like three really
uncomfortable seconds its face is really
messed up yeah thick melting well the
design of scarecrow because he's such a
critical character such a massive
character we've been working on how his
return would take shape ever since the
end of Arkham Asylum we left him out of
Arkham City so we could bring him back
in Arkham Knight gasps mice like fused
into his face and oh right okay so a
volt we've seen scarecrow I mean and the
battement like in Batman Arkham City and
asylum you know there was always number
of Batman's nemec's would appear
throughout the game is this gonna be
another one of those situations are we
gonna see all the old favorites well
this is the thing about Batman like no
Batman experience is complete without an
immense rogues gallery but for us we
were really wanted to focus on the
heroes and the Allies as much as the
enemies and the villains in Arkham
Knight so you know we talked a lot about
the Arkham Knight character himself the
way that he teams up with scarecrow and
how scarecrow is running the show and
uniting the rogues gallery but Batman
also has his own side whether it's
Commissioner Gordon or Barbara Gordon
Oracle and all of the heroes and allies
that give
man support so this being the the epic
conclusion to the trilogy it's this sort
of clash of two sides and and there's
victims on both sides as well you know
they're the decision that Batman has
made to declare war on crime and Gotham
comes at a cost so it's it's a much more
emotional game than we've ever created
before well let's talk in combat right
because obviously when you with asylum
you guys can a set a bar in a way for
how third-person action combat was gonna
go and run and a lot of other games have
like taking that and tweaked it and it's
been really successful for lots of
people how do you know in like your
thirds your third game but the fourth in
this kind of Batman series um with all
these other games implementing the same
mechanics how are you keeping it like
interesting you know it's always about
evolution it's always about iteration
and the good news for the gamers and
Batman fans is that's in our DNA at
Rocksteady you know we we work
incredibly hard always just finding
those little incremental improvements so
new moves like the fear takedown that
you would have seen just before we go
into the penguin weapon cache there in
Arkham Asylum and Arkham City we had the
ability to really change up combat by
just giving one thug an assault rifle or
a shotgun if it's Batman against 20
unarmed thugs he's just gonna clear that
room without too much trouble because
free flow combat really allows you to do
that and dominate but give one of them a
gun and you really have to think about
how you take that guy down so coming
into Arkham Knight we wanted to create
the move that can lay to dominate armed
thugs with that same sort of seamless
dominance so the fear takedown is an
extension of the invisible predator
gameplay and if you get the opportunity
for it you can with one move seamlessly
take out up to three armed thugs and it
breaks up the the kind of flow of combat
make me feel like you're a complete
badass but in a totally different way so
it's just one example of the way that
we're always evolving and always
iterating the free-flow combat system
okay so what about we move
we've talked a bit about the new Gotham
a city I mean have I big as in terms of
scale and how detailed is that like
what's changed from what is basically
this new next gen Hardware enabled you
to add that wasn't there an arc I'm
seeing scale and detail that's the ring
that
always the trade-off you know if you
want to go be can't really go detailed
if you wanna go details can't really go
big but with the horsepower of next-gen
we we decided right batmobile is out
thing Batmobile is the heart and soul of
a game the bad wheel drives really fast
the bat wheel can cover a lot of
territory so we're gonna need a big game
world so the orders I'm not just hitting
the edge of the game when you're driving
at that that sort of top speed so
building out the entirety of Gotham City
that was something we knew we needed to
do but then at the same time you can
just get out of the Batmobile at any
time it's not a driving game it's not a
driving mode bolted onto a Batman game
it's man and machine you've got the
choice how you play this so if you just
want to get out about the mill and walk
down the street each of those buildings
and the water running down the brickwork
and the paint work on that's part of the
graffiti on a telephone box like gamers
are gonna be able to see that up close
and it needs to be beautiful and high
fidelity so be the advantage that you
get with with committing exclusively to
next-gen is you can do that epic scale
with that high fidelity detail that we
just couldn't do with previous platforms
whoo well guys if you're watching at
home when you have any questions for Dax
now is the best time to either tweet
them directly at me that's at cam 4 as
Rob or just chuck them down in the
comments I'm gonna try and pull that up
just now I still have more questions
though you don't get away just yet don't
get it just yet so when can we expect to
get our hands on this no and recently
you know there was a delay and of course
a delay so tell us a bit about that it's
all about Awesomeness as a great spin
there no right don't god it takes a long
time to create really high quality stuff
and as a studio that's what we focus on
quality is critical to us and as we've
been developing the game we've been
looking at where we're at we know where
we want to go and it's just a task of
looking at how much time you have left
and can we hit that awesome level of
quality so in collaboration with our
colleagues at Warner Brothers and DC
comics we took a look at the schedule
and we decided we need more time to make
this awesome because it's the end of the
trilogy right there's a lot of
expectation and we've got to make sure
we hit that quality level otherwise
would be letting ourselves down but more
importantly
Batman fans and gamers so what and when
can we expect to see more than you guys
gonna show off something additional
little bits at Gamescom or is it all
just like Quiet on the Western Front now
until it becomes too late that middle
next year was what's your plan it's
people stay hungry for more like in the
lead-up to e3 it's just like this black
hole of time yeah and it's really hard
to get beyond Lightspeed to look to see
beyond the black hole right absolutely
we've put together a load of content for
e3 we've made that the battle mode
reveal is obviously a massive part of
what the Batmobile brings in terms of
gameplay so beyond e3 stay tuned man
you'll be the first to know all right
no rates what's become and call me up
it's healthy be great if I you know what
I feel that we haven't really talked
enough about the fat 'mobile yet so
let's just go into like tell me
everything everything there is to know
about the Batmobile what we got in terms
of Arsenal you mentioned the two
different modes yeah so when you're in
that kind of tank like battle mode yeah
well what weapons you have your disposal
well it's a completely different mode of
gameplay so Batmobile fundamentals two
modes pursuit mode and battle mode
pursuit mode is all about high speed
driving and then battle mode is all
about your offensive and defensive
abilities when you encounter the forces
of the arkham knight in the streets of
Gotham so the primary weapon that you
have is the 60 mil heavy cannon so it
delivers like massive punch and then
you've got the Vulcan gun as well which
is a higher speed rotary gun so both of
those are used to take down tanks and
you can zoom in and out for precision
hits and then you've got the riot
suppressor on the other side if you come
over the Warner Brothers booth we've
built this thing in full scale so you
can see these up close we've also got
rockets on board so in a demo we showed
a couple of months back
taking out cars and trucks and other
vehicles using rockets so in pursuit you
can fire those and also the missile
barrage that we see at the arrow here to
take out multiple enemies at the same
time so but just drones which is just
wrong exactly come on we're not here to
break the Batman rules right we'd love
Batman so we honor the Batman rule very
well that's a great place to leave I
think back so much for coming on and
talking to us and showing us this
gameplay again sue pleasure so guys
don't go anywhere they look is coming up
next we have a brand
new unannounced VR experience so a game
that's gonna be on both project Morpheus
and oculus rift don't go anywhere
see you in about five minutes